hallo ihr lieben wir sind mitten in der
saison angekommen und heute zeige ich
euch eine richtig leckere grill marinade
die zu fast allen fleischsorten passt zu
allen gefühle sorten zu rindfleisch
zusammen also meiner meinung nach passt
die wirklich zu allen fleischsorten und
wir brauchen wenige zutaten die man
eigentlich immer zu hause hat wir
benötigen gemüsebrühe ketchup sojasauce
honig außerdem essig und currypulver das
fleisch dass ich heute verwende das sind
häschen koteletts es gehen aber auch wie
gesagt alle anderen hintzen sorten ich
habe euch seine ähnliche marinade
übrigens auch schon mal mit
hähnchenschenkel gezeigt und ihr könnt
das ganze auch entweder auf dem grill
oder aber auch im backofen machen ist
ganz euch überlassen
wir werden jetzt ganz einfach alle
zutaten in einer kleinen schüssel
zusammen miteinander verrühren
wir benötigen übrigens kein zusätzliches
salz denn das was wir der gemüsebrühe
haben und in der sojasauce das reicht
vollkommen aus und jetzt gebe ich honig
mit dazu ich finde diese süße in der
marinade muss sein wer keinen honig da
hat kann das auch gerne durch braunen
zucker ersetzen schmeckt auch sehr
lecker und karamellisiert später noch
mal zusätzlich
somit ist die creme marina auch schon
fertig und wir nehmen uns unsere
hähnchenteile nehmen uns einen pinsel
und pinseln sie damit und das ist auch
ein perfektes rezept für eilige für
leute die eben nicht schaffen das ganze
marinieren zu lassen über nacht oder
über ein paar stunden klar könnt ihr das
dann zieht das auch noch mal schön ein
aber was hier bei dieser marinade machen
könnt ist einmal ganz überpinseln und
dann während das auf dem grill ist es
zeit später immer wieder nach pinseln
[Musik]
die marinierten hähnchen koteletts gebe
ich jetzt noch mal bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
gibt es etwas frischhaltefolie drauf und
dann haben sagt kannst du den grill
anschmeißen kissel dahin ja aber auf
jeden fall sache so der grill ist an
jetzt kommen die hähnchen koteletts auf
dem grill und ich mache das immer so
dass sich die hautseite zuerst auf den
grill gebe ein paar minuten das ganze
klasse und drangen dann drehe ich das
und wenn du das immer mal wieder
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir die restliche grill
marinade und bestreichen damit immer
wieder unsere hinten koteletts
und das war es schon fertig sind die
händchen koteletts natürlich könnt ihr
die marinade für hähnchenbrustfilets für
den schenkel für alles mögliche
verwendet
und was ich auch mal gerne mache wenn
ich grad nicht draußen stehen und grille
dann mache ich das gerne im ofen das
funktioniert auch wunderbar das gleiche
prinzip einfach immer wieder mit dem
pinsel nach marinieren
ich hoffe dass ich das rezept gefallen
hat dass ihr das fleißig nach macht
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim grillen
zu bereiten die genauen mengenangaben
stehen wie immer hier unten in der
infobox und ansonsten sage ich bis zum
nächsten mal auf klicks kitchen tschüss
und weil immer so viele fragen wie wer
ist das ganze zeug eigentlich immer
keine sorge das ist nicht haben sich
alleine sondern draußen wurden meine
eltern und da gehen wir gleich hin und
essen das mit den gemeinsam die
marinierten die malediven